[Musique]
avec sa façade un peu austère ce vieux
cinéma de brooklyn est loin
d'impressionner
mais une fois à l'intérieur c'est une
autre histoire bâtie en 1929 l'exploiter
pendant les beaux jours du théâtre de
vaudeville et de l'âge d'or du cinéma
il est pourtant tombé en décrépitude et
a fermé ses portes en 1977
rosenberg a été un des premiers à se
battre pour que le cinéma rouvre ses
portes
et ça n'a pas été facile de lutter
contre l'inévitable déclin des salles de
cinéma doté d'un seul écran de galles
9-8 ne savons ni entièrement rénové au
coût de 90 millions de dollars en 2010
le somptueux kingston revit mais ne
diffuse plus de films
nous avons appris des erreurs du passé
dit stéphanie taurine
il fallait se diversifier aujourd'hui la
salle accueille des concerts du théâtre
et même les fidèles d'une église sur le
rapport avec le cinéma
si la location de l'édifice pour y
filmer quelques séquences comme ce fut
le cas pour de joker
mais où peut-on alors trouver une salle
de cinéma est dépendante à new york
ici il est trop tard le sunshine
tilleuls a été démoli la le ziegfeld a
rendu l'âme en 2016 dans
l'arrondissement du bronx
ce n'est guère mieux on a gardé quand
même ici des éléments du cinéma qui
existait avant ou est ce assez
l'extérieur ici le cinéma dit américaine
est devenue un magasin de vêtements seul
vestige la marquise sur la façade
témoin d'une époque révolue il ya
maintenant beaucoup de différentes
options
oui avec la netflix amazon roule ou et
xetra et ça c'est en compétition
à côté des services de diffusion
continue le coût de l'immobilier et les
méga complexe de cinéma ont aussi
étouffer les petits cinémas new yorkais
en fait le dernier c'était lui le pari
situé en plein coeur de manhattan
inauguré par marlène dietrich après la
seconde guerre mondiale il a fermé ses
portes l'été passé après 71 ans de
service
mais quelques semaines plus tard netflix
vu par certains comme le fossoyeur des
salles obscures le sauver en reprenant
le bail pourrait diffuser ses propres
films au québec des films netflix dont
le confort de ces magnifiques salles
d'autrefois pour l'entreprise c'est une
façon de s'affranchir des contraintes
des grands complexes de cinéma qui
interdisent la diffusion de films en
streaming donc en continu avant environ
trois mois après la sortie sur grand
écran du alcool fringe une loi que le
frigo
netflix sauveur de salles de cinéma pas
vraiment désintéressé par contre car il
lui suffit de projeter ses films comme
dit irishman par exemple sur au moins un
écran de cinéma à new york et à los
angeles pendant une semaine pour
qualifier leur production dans la course
aux oscars
ce fut aussi le cas pour ma web storage
rosenberg salive à l'idée d'un ex-flic
sauveur effet copie can dance
l'idée fait peut-être son chemin puisque
après le cinéma paris l'entreprise
négocie maintenant pour devenir
propriétaire de ce vieux cinéma de los
angeles sur allez-vous de boulevard
un service en ligne pour faire revivre
les bons vieux cinéma peut-être bientôt
sur un grand écran près de chez vous ici
frédéric arnould radio-canada new york
[Musique]